welcome to best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best
life possible for yourself you can just
watch this video or can sign up for
free and get the bonus companion
worksheets that go along with each video
by checking the link
down in the description below all right
today is day 30 and we're going to learn
how to have
more consistency
[Music]
i am stunned by how many people here
don't realize that the quickest path
to happiness or more economics
in business given the context of this
talk
happens to be in the thing that they
love the most yet
they're not willing to each for the next
three to five years to get there let me
explain
it blows me away that if you're
ridiculously
passionate about the teenage mutant
ninja turtles
now stick with me i know this is going
weird
that starting your instagram account
your podcast
and your youtube channel about leonardo
and michelangelo
and putting out that content for a
three-year period
in the long tail of the internet in the
way that niche marketing works
if you focus on that 7 p.m to 2 in the
morning
around that world that literally within
3-4 years the practicality
if you're consistent to making between
50 and 100 000
a year in affiliate ebay links and
sponsorship
around being the foremost expert of
teenage mutant ninja turtles
is a very fascinating thing yeah many
people
here and across this country right now
rushed
to buy cryptocurrency
[Music]
because that's where the gold rush was
i'm just
fascinated by people's passion for the
quick fix versus the marathon
i'm fascinated by people willing to put
in their body to lose 15 pounds
that's some private label from china
versus
eating right and exercising let me
promise you something good and that's
how i want to say it
everything special is [ __ ] hard
you become complacent you become very
civilized in life
you know the worst thing that can happen
to a person you become civilized
when you get to that point where you
believe
that you've arrived when you
my god man i'm up there near michelle
obama on my book
i've done it man i'm good you can coast
i can't i'm good you don't have to do
her oh my god dude you played your man
card
i'm doing i want to be a wildland
firefighter man i retire from the middle
i think i gotta go out there and
dig fire line for three miles i'm 43.
i've done it you should just be
flying first class everywhere everywhere
doing speeches and getting paid crazy
cash
laying in a hotel kicking it man and
that's exactly when it's over
that mindset right there to me is death
i'm not saying you can go as hard as you
did when you were 20.
or now at 43 but there's a new
bar that you must always set in your
life
and once you become complacent and you
become civilized you've arrived
you're no good for anybody the only way
to be a professional
is to work harder than everybody a
professional like a professional
baseball player a boxer is someone
that's better
than everyone else that's why he gets
paid so much to do it that means work
it ain't nothing professional going to
get given to you there's some sacrifice
there's always pain and you know
it's always going to be dark times
because that's part of business every
time you create a new business you got
to struggle a little bit and it takes a
while to build a brand it takes about
five years to be consistent
like my first five years you know i'm
not saying nothing different i've been
saying the same exact stuff
if you go look at um um um backstage and
any kind of argument i had it's always
been consistent it's just people weren't
ready for it they didn't trust it
but after i've been saying it for ten
years five you know five to ten now
it's a brand i have a brand for it i'm
consistent i back it up i'm still here
i'm still up even when you know being an
independent man
because you're putting in the time being
consistent is key and i like that too
let's say netflix didn't exist right and
we still had to watch tv shows uh weekly
let's say an episode of 24 came on back
when it was in the heyday
and i was on a monday and then you're
looking forward to next monday when 24
is coming back but you know what they
just skipped
five weeks and then 24 was on and then
it was on for like four days in a row
and then it was gone for a month he's
like what is
happening you just can't fall in love
with it you can't get into it you can't
get on board so consistency being
consistent with your posting times and
and committing to doing this and
starting that channel is something
that's really going to help you guys out
really going to help your
your channel fashion is changing so fast
and and a competition is coming up every
day with all these young designers
what has kept you going forward like
this
you just somehow you know i've always
admired longevity i've admired
people that uh were not of the only
moment
people that can cap can carry it on
there they're actors there are musicians
there are people that came up in in
in rock and roll and the great ones
stayed
frank sinatra lasted you know
the whole pile of names that you know
paul mccartney and the beatles
they didn't last for five years or ten
years they left it for 40 years
i admired longevity and i admired
consistency
and i admired the individuality of
holding your own
and standing and fighting for what you
believe in and i think if there's
anything that i really believe in is
that
and what made me keep going i didn't get
great reviews every year
i didn't people didn't just say you're
wonderful in fact
they couldn't care less ralph lauren but
the consumer loved browford
it's not the fashion editor as someone
who's been consistently creating content
and sharing content for almost two
decades now i speak
from experience and i gotta tell you
being consistent with your content
creation
it is so important it's actually one of
the biggest factors in our company's
success so when it comes to coming up
with things to write about or talk about
or teach about
i really do believe that i can never run
out of ideas because literally
there's always more where that came from
look people
we live in an abundant ever-changing
ever
expanding universe it's literally
impossible to run out of ideas i promise
you
now this doesn't mean that i never feel
like i run out of ideas or that i don't
occasionally wonder if i'm tapped out i
mean believe me i have
those moments but when that happens i
remember
my magical mantra that there's always
more where that came from
and it changes everything like that
because there's always another story to
tell
there's always another way for me to
serve there's always someone who could
use a helping hand or a kind
word or a reminder about how freaking
great they are and from that space
ideas always always come i didn't have
that big of an audience when i started
it almost three years ago
i had a pretty decent size but i had the
relationships with influencers
from the years of previous stuff with my
other business
so i was able to get a lot of great
influencers on because i do an
interview podcast and
i was just consistent i said i'm going
to do it every week for this year
and i do one once a week and then the
second year i said i'm going to do it
twice a week this year because people
were asking for more yeah
the third year now uh people said we
want more so that's what i'm gonna do
three times a week wow
and so i'm at 200 out of 40 episodes
almost right now
over three year period and i still feel
like i'm scratching the surface
but i'm almost three years in at the end
of three years and i still love it so i
think a lot of people get into a podcast
because they feel like they need to do
it or they want to do it
and they'll talk about a topic for six
months and then they're burnt out yeah
so i think we're gonna do a podcast do
something that you're committed to for
the next three
five ten years yeah if you really want
to see it grow and build momentum around
your brand
and have an impact what would you
attribute your success to
on youtube um uh
well i'll do tech videos so i think that
the obvious answer there is tech
has been interesting and important for
so long that
just being in a tech space generally for
that long has has done a lot for it yeah
um the channel itself i mean there's
plenty of other successful tech channels
but
it has its own unique style it has a
consistent voice
it's been me for 10 years yeah um so i
guess just
if you combine all those factors
consistency plus
text staying interesting that's that's
mainly it i get asked that a lot about
like
you know can i point to a certain video
or a
date or month or something like what
happened
to go from like nothing to where it is
now because i've
from to this day i look back and it's
mainly just like you can look at charts
even it's just a sort of an upward slope
from zero videos to a thousand videos
uh you know it's obviously when you get
to certain points like
the reputability is that a word the
reputability of the channel becomes more
significant so you're more likely to
subscribe to a tech guy with a million
subscribers talking about something you
should buy than a guy with 100
so that's helped but i feel like uh
consistency again is
major really i hit it big in real estate
by time i was 26 27 years old just by
taking action knocking on a million
doors and finally got someone to do a no
money down deal with me when i was 20
and
then another one and i rolled that to
the next deal the next deal and
consistent action
consistent action and and consistent you
know failing and getting back up right
the the space between failures is really
a huge determining factor of your
success right it's like
if you can fail fast you can win quicker
you get up you start writing for
yourself and then you start writing
first audience of five and then you
start writing for
you know probably a large luxury
audience and it's so funny because i
think because my career has gotten a
little more visible in the last two
years people are always like oh my god
this is amazing like how this like
overnight success thing so
i started this blog what like 10 and a
half years ago
right literally the 10-year overnight
success right exactly
10 and a half years ago um and
i wrote every single day for
two years before anybody just said
anything to me about anything other than
my friends
right um and one day i wrote this post
it was called don't carpe diem and again
it is a post i would have scrapped
i thought i didn't think it was good my
dad called me after my dad was my main
reader
okay i love it yes most of my feedback
is still is from my dad
he called me and he was like he went uh
about the today's
essay this freaking
essay went completely viral
and more than a million shares right and
it was like this teeny little blog
and then you know two weeks later i was
my inbox was full
of um letters from agents in new york
and
two weeks after that i was in new york
city at an auction for a book
based on the blog but the but i had
never
ever one time promoted or tried to do
anything
to all i did was sit my butt down and
write
my heart out each day for the small
audience that was there
and it just organically turned into the
book and
all the wider things and that's how the
nonprofit started too healthcare
is shifting from treatment to prevention
going to the dentist regularly is
important
not just when you were in pain
brushing his teeth twice a day every day
and visiting the dentist twice a year
could have prevented the pain he's
experiencing
now why wait for problems to
occur in our life if we can proactively
address them and save ourselves
so much pain going to the gym regularly
is important not just when you want a
summer body
small acts of love and kindness
done regularly are important not just
the big gifts given on birthdays
and anniversaries it is the small things
done rightly and consistently
that make a huge difference in our lives
success is less about intensity
and more about consistency
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that
it's time for the best live 30 questions
of the day
it's not enough to just watch a video
you have to do something about it so
pull out your worksheets
and if you don't have the worksheets you
can get them for free using the link in
the description below
here we go question number one where do
you need to be more consistent in your
life number two
what's the out you need to stop giving
yourself and number three
how will you stop being complacent when
it gets hard
and if you're doing the best life 30
challenge with me i want to celebrate
you give me a hashtag
bestlife30 down in the comments below
lack of consistency is one of the
biggest reasons why entrepreneurs fail
one of the biggest reasons you're a
genius you have great ideas you want to
serve
you know you're capable of more and you
have these moments of inspiration and
moments of boldness and moments of
massive
productivity and focus and clarity but
it's not consistent
and that's why most entrepreneurs will
lose
because you might crush it on a saturday
or sunday or
monday but then tuesday wednesday
thursday friday
you fall back down until the next
saturday when you're up and flying again
it's not enough it's much more about
what you do every day
you are what you consistently do it's a
huge problem for entrepreneurs so let's
fix them
number one if you are a part-time
entrepreneur if you work for someone
else
you're part-time entrepreneur you need
to make sure that every single day
you're working on your business
every single day you have to work on
your business no matter what even if
it's for 15 minutes at night
every single day you cannot let momentum
die
even just to show yourself that you
can't even if it's a crazy long day
and your boss is yelling at you and you
come home and your spouse is
angry and your kids are even then you
have to spend 15 minutes on your
business half an hour in your business
every single day you cannot let the
momentum die
don't disappoint yourself number two if
you're already full time in your
business great
you need to have ceo time every day in
your business ceo time
time where you spend being the ceo what
does that mean it's different for
different entrepreneurs
but when you're working on the business
instead of in it if you spend all time
just working in the business just
putting out fires and never growing
guess what you're never going to grow if
you never have ceo time built into your
business you will never be a ceo
and so you need to make sure that every
day you have ceo time built into your
business again maybe it's only half an
hour
but in that half an hour you're spending
time growing your company you're gonna
start seeing results
and my last tip is i want you to start
your morning off powerfully i want you
to chart your start i want you to have a
morning routine
that inspires you that makes you feel
bold most people what do they do when
they wake up
first thing they do is they hit the
snooze button what does that mean it
means last night you set a goal
i'm going to wake up at a certain time
right i'm going to wake up at 6 a.m 5
a.m 7 00 am 12
noon i don't care what time you have to
wake up you set a goal you're going to
wake up
and then the very first thing that you
do how you start your day every day you
say i am not going to hit my bowl today
that's how you start your day that's how
most of america starts your day they say
i'm not going to hit my goal today
how do you think you're going to go off
and have an amazing day and crush it and
go
hit your crazy big goals and ambitions
that you have as an entrepreneur
when you tell yourself and you reinforce
it every morning that you are the kind
of person who doesn't hit their goals
you got to change that you got to wake
up wake up when you say you're gonna
wake up
get out of bed when you say you're gonna
get out of bed that's step one
then step two is what is a morning
routine that sets you up for success
most people wake up like it's an
accident they wake up you check your
phone
you're responding to other people's
emergencies and their agenda for your
time
that's not how you need to start your
day successful people they own their
morning
what does your morning look like and
we've all felt inspired and bold at some
point
you felt it you've been bold you've been
inspired at some point in your life
great whatever that thing was it made
you feel bold unstoppable inspired
put that into your morning routine maybe
just watching the video maybe it's
reading the book
maybe it's doing an act of kindness
maybe it's meditating maybe it's prayer
whatever it is with intention because
some of you have a morning routine
already i'm talking to you
you have a morning routine already but
you're not crushing it every day you're
not coming out of that morning routine
feeling bold inspired consistently
that's what we're talking about
consistency here sometimes you just go
through the motions of your morning
routine
sometimes you just pray but you're not
really connecting sometimes you just
watch a video but you're making your
breakfast you're brushing your teeth and
you're not paying attention
with intention to your morning routine
you must come out of your morning
routine
every single day feeling bold
unstoppable and confident
if you did that if you woke up every day
on time like you say you're going to
you're not getting the snooze button you
get out of bed and then you did the
thing that made you feel bold
powerful and unstoppable every single
day holy cow i guarantee you your life
one year from today will look
dramatically different
than where you are right now consistency
is the game
you are what you consistently do and i
want to see you win
if you want to join the best life 30
challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to stay consistent
check the playlist right there next to
me continue to believe
and i'll see you there